cbs news legal analyst rikki kleman
joins us now she also has been following
the charges in court cases against bill
cosby
for us since 2015. ricky good morning
good morning as you heard jerica say
bill cosby told her he felt vindicated
did the judge in this ruling vindicate
bill cosby no not in any way this is not
about exoneration or vindication
bill cosby is not pronounced innocent he
is not even pronounced
not not guilty what this violation
was seen by the court and remember the
court
gave a six to one opinion about a
constitutional
process violation it was four to three
about what the remedy was
so what the court did was it said
that there was once a promise by a
prosecutor
that bill cosby relied on that promise
of no prosecution
to his detriment because he answered
questions
at a deposition in a lawsuit brought by
andrea constand the victim in this case
then those statements were used against
him
in a criminal trial after he was told
they would not be used against him
of course the judge basically said that
the prosecutors didn't play fair
the prosecutors it's not that they
didn't play fair
it's that they literally violated the
constitutional right
of the 14th amendment to due process of
law
we have to remember that the criminal
justice system
is a system that works because people
trust
each other's agreements so that's why
the court said
if prosecutor one makes a promise like
this
and you rely upon it to your detriment
it must be reversed people surprised
were you surprised by this ricky
i the reason that i don't think i was
shocked is because this court only takes
two to four percent
of the cases that they're asked to take
cosby asked for a lot of errors to look
at they only looked at two they were
very
interested in this situation ricky
people are angry they're frustrated
should they be angry at the initial d.a
who entered into this agreement with
bill cosby or the
prosecutor who brought the case and now
had it overturned i think that anger
will serve only to upset
the whole thought of women coming
forward
i understand why they're angry i was a
sex crimes prosecutor i sat on the board
of a rape treatment center
if i were one of these women or any
woman i would be
angry however what they have to remember
is that a jury of his peers found him
guilty and that that is a really
important factor
the fact that there's a process or a
constitutional due process
violation does not change his area of
guilt
remember this in the remedy which means
no further trial because of due process
that became the four to three decision
and they said it was a rare
remedy but that it was necessary
all right ricky klingman thank you
always good to have you thank you
god